[Musique]
bienvenue à yopougon un quartier
populaire d'abidjan que nous avons
baptisé x était porteur comme dans un
film américain
je vous présente ignace mon géniteur là
tu me fatigues
pourquoi tu es toujours un creux de
voûte des oublis cette belle femme c'est
fanta ma mère tu poses trop de questions
mais je n'ai rien dit encore tu as trop
curieuse les nouvelles vont vite dans ce
quartier j'ai deux meilleures amies
adjoint
je nous vois déjà dans mon grand salon
de coiffure acheté par mon mari franck
la chaux et bintou blague au choc une
grande case is lucky de soi ya dans
cette chanson tienne cofat ans
conditionna de la bride
mais ce qui rend yop city si intéressant
ce sont des histoires des cars qui font
vivre et ce quartier les filles de york
city son deuil éventuelle en garde
[Musique]
d'elle comme un cacao qui sèchent au
soleil
tu es enceinte energy va me dis qu'est
ce voile ou se font rien qui t'as fait
ça que je vais le tuer le fils d'ahidjo
viennent de cloche c'est connu on parle
au village ont tout va bien là-bas
quelqu'un qui nous sommes à sept ans
hier tous vos campagnes on va voir le
père de ta grossesse
tu sors moi qui j'espère
[Musique]
il
mais regarde
mon gré goual à une bois que du
champagne et s'habille chez le plus
grand couturier de paris tati
[Musique]